digamos que tenemos dos gases con
temperaturas diferentes que están en
contacto mutuamente
aquí estoy dibujando amigas magenta
estas son las moléculas de migas magenta
y este sistema está en contacto con el
gas azul de aquí
y digamos que justo cuando estamos
comenzando nuestro experimento o
simulación el gas magenta tiene una
temperatura más alta
y nuestro gas azul tiene una temperatura
más baja vamos a recordar que es la
temperatura especialmente si lo queremos
ver a nivel molecular
la temperatura es proporcional a la
energía cinética promedio por lo que
estas moléculas estarán vibrando y
chocando entre sí cada una de ellas
tendrá energía cinética y el promedio de
todas ellas será proporcional a la
temperatura vamos a ilustrar la energía
cinética de estas moléculas
quizá esta va hacia este lado esta otra
va en esta dirección estaba para acá
esta otra va para allá esta va así
estaba acá
noten que todas tienen diferente
dirección y diferente magnitud
todas tienen velocidad diferente y
diferentes rapidez todas se golpean
entre sí y se transfieren energía
cinética transfiriendo el momento de una
a otra
la temperatura es proporcional a la
energía cinética promedio del sistema en
cambio en el gas azul sus moléculas
también tendrán la energía cinética pero
su promedio será menor esta está así
estaba para acá estaba para allá está
está así y todas son diferentes pero el
promedio será menor espero que vean que
estas flechas magenta son más grandes
que las flechas azules aunque no todas
tienen que ser iguales a lo mejor ésta
tiene más energía cinética pero el
promedio de todas será menor que el
promedio del gas magenta
este es nuestro estado inicial que es lo
que nos imaginamos que puede pasar
antes de esto podemos imaginar que las
moléculas del gas magenta están
colisionando entre ellas y las moléculas
del gas azul están colisionando con las
moléculas azules pero ahora ambas
estarán colisionando entre sí se pueden
imaginar a esta molécula de aquí
colisionando con esta otra molécula son
transfiriéndole algo de su energía
cinética
después de la colisión esta podría
rebotar hacia esta dirección vamos a
ponerlo en otro color primero está
colisiona con aquella cual le transfiere
algo de su energía cinética y rebota en
esta dirección mientras que esta otra se
va a mover más rápido en esta dirección
noten que tenemos una transferencia de
energía después de esta colisión paso a
energía cinética de esta molécula a esta
otra molécula y esto va a ocurrir en
todo el sistema conforme las moléculas
más rápidas y con mayor energía cinética
golpeen a las otras moléculas les van a
transferir parte de su energía cinética
tendremos una transferencia de energía
que va desde la temperatura más grande
hacia la menor temperatura
y podemos considerar esto como
transferencia de energía térmica
pues estamos hablando de temperatura y
todo lo que tiene que ver con
temperatura se le llama térmico
si comenzamos con un mayor promedio de
energía cinética aquí y tenemos menor
promedio de energía cinética tendremos
transferencia de energía de las
moléculas magenta a las azules pasará de
la mayor temperatura hacia la de menor
temperatura y la energía que se
transfiere le llamamos y seguramente
ustedes han escuchado mucho de esta
palabra calor
este gas más caliente de aquí va a
calentar a este gas más frío y la forma
en que se realiza esta transferencia de
energía es mediante la colisión de las
partículas ya esta transferencia de
energía mediante la transferencia de
momento le llamamos conducción o
conducción térmica
es la forma en que muchos de ustedes han
experimentado la transferencia de calor
seguramente muchos de ustedes han tomado
una cazuela o sartén que al principio
está fría por lo que las partículas de
la cazuela o sartén tienen una menor
energía cinética aunque bueno aquí no
voy a poder dibujarlas todas y ahora la
ponemos sobre el fuego vamos a dibujar
el fuego aquí y aquí solo me estoy
fijando en calentar el metal de la
cazuela no me fijo si hay algo adentro
de ella este fuego va a calentar la base
de la cazuela primero
y esto va a ocurrir principalmente
mediante la conducción térmica el fuego
no es más que partículas de aire super
calientes y esas partículas super
calientes van a golpear a las moléculas
del metal de la cazuela por lo que la
energía cinética de las partículas del
metal va a aumentar
esta parte de la cazuela se comenzará a
calentar y justo al encender la estufa
la base de la cazuela estará caliente y
la boca de la cazuela o lo de arriba aún
estará frío si esperamos unos momentos
las partículas calientes del metal de
abajo comenzarán a vibrar y a golpearse
entre ellas ya transferir su energía
cinética por lo que eventualmente
también se calentará la parte de arriba
de la cazuela y quedará muy caliente la
forma en que se calentó la parte de
arriba de la cazuela fue mediante
conducción térmica
la base se calentó primero comenzó a
golpear a sus moléculas vecinas y hacer
que éstas a su vez comenzarán a vibrar
al transferir la energía cinética por lo
que se da transferencia de calor desde
la región con mayor temperatura hacia la
región de menor temperatura